يبدو ان حمله طاقه مع الشرطه الايرانيه
التي مورست ضد المحتاجين لم تكن كافيه
بنسبه للنظام حيث تشير الانباء الى اقاله
قائد الشرطه حسين اشتري بامر من خمري
الاقاله برررتها وكاله انباء برنه
الايرانيه التابعه لوزاره الرياضه والشباب
بانتهاء مهمه اشتري في قياده الشرطه ليحل
محله احمد رضا ردان قائد شرطه طهران
السابق لكن وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه
المعارضه شددت على ان السبب يرجع لفشل
اشتري في كبح لاحتجاجات المستمره منذ
منتصف سبتمبر الماضي
الشريعي الذي عين في منصبه عام 2015 وجهت
لهم انتقادات من خامنئي نفسه بحسب قناه
ايران انترناشونال لعدم كفاءته في ايقاف
تمدد الاحتجاجات وبنظر الى تاريخ اشتري
الذي بدا حياته في صفوف الحارس الثوري
وكان احد قاده معي لاحتجاجات السابقه التي
كان اخرها عام 19 فان انباء اقالته تشير
الى مدى تسع الغضب وربما القلق داخل
النظام من استمراريه لاحتجاجات وزخمها